-Our next guest
is an iconic illusionist
who has won 21 Emmys, earned
11 Guinness World Records,
and has been named
a living legend
by the US Library of Congress.
His book, "David Copperfield's
History of Magic,"
is available now.
Get your copy...
before it disappears.
Please welcome to the show
the always great
David Copperfield!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hello, David.
-How are you? How are you?
-I'm doing very well.
I want to begin by asking --
-I'm changing my name to Gaia,
by the way.
I'm changing my name to Gaia.
-It's a very hot name right now.
Good.
Getting in on the ground floor
is a good idea.
What is the difference, David,
between an illusionist
and a magician?
-Well, my joke is, if you
call yourself an illusionist,
you get to make 20% more,
which is true.
-All right, so sort of like
a classy magician.
-That's right.
-Now, I will speak to the fact
that I have seen your show live.
Not only was it
incredibly memorable,
even if it was made more so
by the fact that I was there for
Andy Samberg's bachelor party,
and then afterwards,
we went backstage,
and you had
a very specific illusion
built just for Andy.
-I did. Well, what happened
was I was shocked
that you guys were there
because, you know,
bachelor party --
you have strippers
or David Copperfield?
"Hmm. Okay.
David Copperfield. Perfect."
So, I'm doing the show,
and backstage,
my whole crew is building
a "dick in the box" box
because Andy was there.
And, you know,
they're crafting it.
The glue is drying,
and the show's over with.
And I come backstage.
You were very kind to come
backstage and say hello.
And we levitated a box
with my magic.
Here is a floating
dick in the box.
[ Laughter ]
Fantastic.
-Yes.
-So, you have -- Over the years,
you've basically built
a museum of magic.
You are in it right now.
It is your sort of
self-curated museum.
It is not open to the public.
One of the reasons is
there are so many secrets
that would be revealed
if people saw it.
So now you've put together
this book,
which is sort of a peek inside.
Was it fun to sort of
pick out your favorite pieces
and tell the backstory of them?
-It was awesome because
there's so many amazing stories
of the ladies and gentlemen
who inform this art form,
and the art form of magic
really has influenced art,
influenced design,
influenced robotics, technology.
Incredible things.
The first smart home to exist
was a magic effect.
Robert-Houdin.
His actual house door
is behind me there.
It's a door that opens up,
you know, by magic.
And now every grocery store,
you know --
Every CVS we go to
to get the shot,
you go through that --
That was a trick at the time.
So all kinds of things
were affected by magic,
and I get to tell those stories
in a really wonderful way.
At this museum, you know,
we've had, you know --
Guillermo del Toro will be here,
and he'll get very emotional
because the cinema was invented
as a magic effect.
Movies was a magic trick.
And Georges Méliès
took that magic effect
and made it into something
that we could tell stories with.
So much of what we live
in our life
has been prototyped
by magicians.
-Do you remember
the first trick you did?
Was magic something that had
come to you at a very young age?
-I made my teacher disappear.
[ Laughter ]
I was very popular.
But then she came back, and
all my street cred was lost.
-You, uh --
This is a true story that seems
like it shouldn't be.
The secrets to your tricks
are hidden somewhere
so that whenever you are gone,
people could look
and read your secrets.
Where have you hidden
the secrets to your tricks?
-On the Moon.
-"On the Moon" is a real answer.
How did you get them
to the Moon?
-Well, what happened was
we're able to put them
on nickel discs.
The Arch Mission, my friends
at the Arch Mission,
were able to etch my secrets
into a nickel disc.
And nickel doesn't degrade.
That element doesn't degrade.
It'll be there
for a billion years.
And those disc
with all my secrets
were sent to the Moon
in an Israeli lander.
Unfortunately,
it didn't land nice.
It landed -- It crash-landed.
But the things don't --
They still exist there
on the Moon.
They're a little harder to find.
But someday,
if you are on the Moon
and you have a metal detector
and a microscope,
you can actually see my magic.
In fact,
we're going to try again
with those secrets and the book.
So the book and my secrets
are going to the Moon.
So if you don't buy the book,
someday you can go to the Moon
and actually read the book
on the Moon.
-Are you worried that if
an alien race ever found
that first, they'd think Earth
was just a planet of magicians?
-[ Laughs ] That's true.
And it would kill my career.
[ Laughter ]
-Is it true that you were
once held up at gunpoint
and did a trick
to get out of it?
-Yeah, that was
a pretty stupid day.
I was held up at gunpoint
with my crew, in fact.
About six of us were there.
They held a gun to our faces,
and everybody
gave their passports
and their money, smartly.
I, stupidly, just by instinct,
did what magicians call
a pocket dodge,
which is where you could show
your pockets empty
and they're not really empty.
And, you know, I didn't
want to give up my passport
and my money, and I should have,
but it worked out okay.
The criminals were caught, and
I could've got my stuff back.
But if you're out there
listening
and you're able to do
the pocket-dodge effect,
don't do it.
Give them the money. It's okay.
-Now, obviously in that moment,
it must have been heartbreaking
because you probably realized
they didn't recognize you
as David Copperfield.
-[ Laughs ]
-Because I'll tell you,
if I had a gun
and asked David Copperfield
to empty his pockets
and he was like, "Nothing,"
I'd be like, "Hold on."
[ Laughter ]
"I'm gonna check 'em myself,
Copperfield."
-I probably did that move
because --
I was really somebody,
you know, had some talent.
-This is very exciting.
You actually not only have the
history of magic in your museum,
you have a piece of history
from our show.
We actually referenced him
tonight.
You have the Sea Captain photo.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. We've got
the Sea Captain from your house
right here in 3-D.
But he doesn't have a body.
-What foul black magic is this?
-He won't shut up.
-May every fish you ever eat
have higher mercury levels!
-I thought
I'd make him disappear.
Is that okay with you?
-I won't go quietly,
Copperfield!
You may banish me,
but I will spend eternity
haunting your soul!
And I can't find your soul,
I'll take a ghost [bleep]
in your lawn!
[ Cackling ]
-Let's do this.
-[Bleep] you, David Copperfield.
N-o-o-o-o-o!
Don't send me away.
I promise I'll be good.
[ Sobbing ]
-He's still talking.
-I will have my revenge,
Copperfield!
-Oh, my God.
David, thank you so much
for finally getting rid
of him for us.
-[ Laughs ]
My pleasure. My pleasure.
-David Copperfield, everybody.
"David Copperfield's
History of Magic"
is available now.